hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
i'm
just checking in on you i'm just
checking in to see how the new normal
and working from home
and and and sticking your kids in a
school pod is working out for everybody
all while
socially distancing in um
2020 sorry i was trying to throw it all
in there
how are you i am on the road echo echo i
got a live room here baby
old freckles old pumpkin face himself
i was [ __ ] doing uh i did some shows
i did two shows last night
two shows tonight before i got two
tonight two to friday two
saturday that's my new that's my new
normal
instead of doing one big show i do like
48 small ones
that's it that is [ __ ] it
so i want to thank everybody uh
for putting this thing together this
place where i'm at ridgefield i guess
connecticut is
the best setup that i've been to it's
incredible
there's like a giant hill i'll take you
through the whole [ __ ] thing here
okay
tuesday night i was essentially on a
patch of grass where people usually
probably play touch football
behind a motel and it was funny they had
this little slab
blue slab maybe six inches off the
ground
under this [ __ ] you know you know
those those tailgate tents
there's no sides to them you know they
just have like the four posts and then
the thing on top
standing underneath that but then the
people too far away so you kind of get
to walk out to the grass
you know and i'm doing my show
and i'm having a great time the people
are [ __ ] awesome
it was oddly amazing it was just [ __ ]
it was great to hear people laughing and
making them laugh again
and i'm in the middle of my show and all
of a sudden
you know there's this [ __ ] creepy
little stream behind me but you can't
see because there's all these shrubs and
[ __ ]
and all of a sudden this lady
from next door you know it was this
little split entry house that i was
making fun of because they had a new
roof on it but they
had the old shutters i was joking out
that makes the shutters just stand out
how [ __ ] old they are like having a
new suit in old shoes right
and this lady came over and uh
with like her dogs and [ __ ] i just sort
of looked over i just saw i was like hey
you know welcome to the show whatever
she gets in it with a security guard and
i'm just like sorry is there a problem
what's going on and then she just starts
yelling at me
i have rights and i can hear you all the
way in my house and i shouldn't have to
listen to that filth
yeah i don't know stuff you know and i
did say
[ __ ] and i was yelling so you know i'm
not a dick so i said oh sorry about that
maybe i kind of toned it down a little
bit we'll send you gift bags ah
i just kept one of these people they
just wanted to yell
and it was uh you know she started
wagging her fingers like don't you
wag your finger at me you know get to
this whole ridiculous thing
and she just kept screaming and yelling
and screaming and yelling
and screaming and yelling and no matter
what i did
i just couldn't defuse it and uh
i don't know then she started like
walking away and [ __ ] and then she came
back
you know was a [ __ ] mess and then i
didn't know what to do
because i felt bad for her it's like you
know she didn't want to hear the show
they usually had this white noise
machine and i guess the wind blew it
over and it broke
a few shows ago before i got there so
she was hearing everywhere and then you
know
then the worst part is i found out
that she didn't live in that split entry
that i was making fun of
she lived across the street and the
person who lived in the split entry was
actually listening to the show and
enjoying it
and i was [ __ ] on his house
[Laughter]
um so i felt bad about i mean i wasn't
like [ __ ] on it [ __ ] on it but
it was a split entry and i was just
making fun of how i
never liked the split entry um
and stupid silly [ __ ] jokes about
that of you know
it's not a house if you can jump off it
and you can't kill yourself
you know it's like they started to build
a house and then they just quit
and just like all right let's just make
the basement the first floor and we'll
just [ __ ]
have a one and a half floor it's a top
floor
uh yeah that's elitist that's what we do
i'm from hollywood
now i don't know i was just [ __ ]
sitting there i was just making i just
saw it i was making fun of it there was
a u-haul
in the [ __ ] parking lot you know of a
motel one of the saddest
situations you could be in i was making
fun just [ __ ] ripping on people when
i was there and that's all i was doing
and then that lady came over
i felt really bad but then i found out
she's kind of been doing that like every
show and she lived across the street and
i was like all right i get it but you
know you also have to respect the fact
there are people out there that don't
they don't want to listen to those kinds
of words you know
it goes all the way back to gen the
great janet jackson and her titty
popping out during the super bowl
and all these [ __ ] people who watch
free porn all the time were like wait
man like what's the big deal
well here's what the big deal is it was
on network television
and a lot of people just you know don't
have cable not a lot but people don't
have cable because they don't want to
watch people
you know cursing and shooting each other
and [ __ ]
on screen so they put on a super bowl
they're watching a football game and all
of a sudden there's an iconic titty
[ __ ]
on their screen um
which by the way was totally planned it
was not a wardrobe malfunction it was
totally designed
to be ripped off they were trying to do
something shocking it came off perfectly
her clothes were not
ripped it came off like [ __ ] velcro
it was perfectly round
circle right around her titty right
she went out of her way to get her
nipple pierced the whole [ __ ] thing
was playing and just the way she
she didn't reach up and cover herself
she sort of framed her titty
so the whole thing was planned right
janet took the [ __ ] heat
the [ __ ] instinct guy just sort of
[ __ ] moonwalked out of the picture
and everybody got mad at him
um you know which i didn't understand
because wasn't he revealed the titty so
even if he [ __ ] didn't own up to it
he still did us as solid
[Laughter]
um so my apologies to that lady uh
you know i tried to clean it up a little
bit but they turned the sound down for
the second show and she didn't come back
her and the two sad dogs i think dogs
know when they have a crazy owner
you know what i mean they're still loyal
to a fault
they're like all right i don't feel like
running away and trying to become a wolf
again so
i'll stick it out with this person but
uh you know you'd think they would learn
from how cool
i am you know because dogs are [ __ ]
cool
you know dogs are definitely cool
[ __ ] people oh for god's sakes when
can i ever [ __ ] type in my password
right the first time
can that ever happen i don't think it
does um
i worked last night i missed the celtics
game but just looking at the scoring
line
it just looks like you know miami just
was
just a little more relentless than we
were
um up three games to one what a playoff
run they're having i think that's only
they've only had two losses
um so i'm looking forward to them i
imagine that they're gonna play the
lakers
i feel like the lakers did what they
need to do buy up all the talent
available in the [ __ ] league
i am so [ __ ] rooting against them
if they went out and bought another
[ __ ] you know
another great [ __ ] center they've
been doing it my
for 50 years of my [ __ ] life wilt
chamberlain kareem abdul-jabbar
shaquille o'neal lebron james when's it
gonna end
hey la when are you actually gonna be
smart enough to draft somebody your own
[ __ ] guy
they just can't [ __ ] do it they don't
need to they don't need to
they got the [ __ ] movie stars for the
guys to bang and they got the perfect
weather
um it's a hard thing to compete with
although golden state did do it for a
minute
it somehow convinced all those people to
go up and hang out in oakland
well you can go to san francisco you
want to uh
zhuzh it up a little bit okay let's not
forget you know we got uh
we got san jose we got santa uh
we got a [ __ ] fresno
you know if you want to keep it real go
to a tough town
not saying oakland isn't tough but i
think a lot of people who can't afford
san francisco have now
moved in to oakland which has lowered
their uh their their
ranking of tough towns and they got
sacrament they got sacked down
that's a tough it's a tough sell san
francisco is not a tough sell
if you got athlete money i think i don't
know i don't know what the deal is i
don't know what's going on up there
i just heard there's another fire in
[ __ ] l.a jesus christ
jesus christ how come how come no what's
what's the name of the people that
[ __ ] had the gender-neutral thing but
by the way
they're saying that that's a stupid
thing to get upset about i mean you can
on a certain level but like all those
other fires were created
by all of us having flat screen tvs on
every other [ __ ]
you know that and lightning um
but we did make it extra dry
so i don't know i did see a couple
commercials of people talking about you
know i'm working for this company we're
making [ __ ] windmills because i want
to try to
so my kid knows that i did try to do
something
[Music]
i don't think it's going to be easy but
i think we're going to do it i think the
scientists that for some reason nobody's
listening to
not enough people are listening to
during this [ __ ] pandemic
because new york was doing great i guess
they had another [ __ ] breakout in
queens they should go out and arrest
everybody that went out and got [ __ ]
coveted that's what thing you just gotta
[ __ ]
you gotta do it you gotta like round up
all the jerk-offs
and you are a [ __ ] jerk-off if you're
not wearing a [ __ ] mask you're a
[ __ ]
jerk-off you're lazy you're selfish
you're a [ __ ] jerk off unfucking
believe the fact that you wouldn't
listen to a [ __ ] scientist look at
you go back and look at your high school
transcript
you [ __ ] dope you know what it does
it just really fee that this whole thing
just
feeds into to to people's egos
panic and their their uh their sense of
control
and there's a lot of [ __ ] control
freaks there's a lot of egomaniacs out
there
and there's a lot of [ __ ] scared
little chickens out there
and they can't handle this [ __ ] thing
so what their way to
take control of it is to rebel against
it you know
egomaniacs want to be right that's not
what's going on i'll tell you what's
really going on there's
actually a [ __ ] conspiracy to take
away your rights this is the dumbest and
i love a conspiracy but like
do you really think the entire [ __ ]
world got on board for this
it's the new world order um why am i
doing a southern accent like there's not
crazy people
dude it's the new [ __ ] world order
um all right
so anyway connecticut jesus christ what
a beautiful state this is
you know sort of the have and have-nots
the epitome of it
that's what i've noticed out here you
know where i'm staying in the middle of
nowhere
is there's all these farms out here and
i've noticed
some farms have old pickup trucks parked
in front of them and others have like
porsches and audis
and mercedes so there's like two types
of people up here you got the banker
that went and bought an old farm and
then converted it into some [ __ ] i
don't know what
and then you got like someone who's
actually a farmer growing food for
people so
it's very interesting and i would lie to
you okay if you didn't if
if i didn't think about taking some of
my bozo bucks here
and buying something small after being
out there in the uh
the fires and all of that and it's
[ __ ]
it's eden out here it's really really
gorgeous
uh but i do have to tell you i do love
los angeles
even though it shouldn't be there i do
[ __ ] love it uh
so who knows anyways like i said like
i've been saying god bless the [ __ ]
scientists and the firefighters and
everybody
[ __ ] doing the work for all of our
other sins you know one
[ __ ] [ __ ] goes out and [ __ ] a bat
and now we're in this goddamn situation
right
and i'm all for blaming the bad [ __ ]
or eater whatever the [ __ ] he did i
don't know if he went down on the bat i
have no idea what the [ __ ] happened but
i will tell you this
all of these [ __ ] selfish [ __ ] who
just don't wear a [ __ ] mask
and have like this you know there was a
[ __ ] guy
my first show saying yeah i don't wear a
mask and i just make sure i stay six
feet bro
it's like yeah dude you can't be
bothered look at you life has not even
touched you he
he looked like like like right out of
central casting for [ __ ] a trust fund
kid
and he doesn't give a [ __ ] he's got
money
he didn't give he was sitting there with
his tan legs and his bare feet the guy
was actually [ __ ] like you can't get
mad at the guy
he was born into [ __ ] a certain level
of wealth
beautiful head of hair
just some people just it takes a long
time before life touches him
and he just he looked like he was still
brand new out of the box and he was like
closer to 40 that he was 30.
and you just have to look at somebody
like that and be he doesn't know any
better
he doesn't know anything other than just
doing whatever the [ __ ] he wants to do
and uh as was frustrating as that is to
deal with with something like this you
just have to understand that that's
exactly how i would be behaving
if i looked like him and was born into
his world now i'm judging the [ __ ] out
of the guy but
i don't think i'm wrong you know it's
funny after that lady next door yelled
at me
and i was like ah i feel bad or whatever
that guy actually yelled out he goes
don't worry bill we got your back
and i said dude you've had you you
haven't had anybody's back your entire
[ __ ] life
you do not look like a knock-around guy
as club soda kenny says
um anyway so i did catch up on uh some
moto gp i watched the last race the one
there from italy jesus i had never seen
so many people crash
like not bad ones nobody high sided just
you know going around turns and just
[ __ ] wiping out one guy [ __ ] wiped
out twice
picked up his bike got back on it and
[ __ ] wiped out again and i think the
same turn turn number one
um uh congratulations to maverick
vinales
if you're not watching you can get
caught up on the motogp.com that's what
i've been doing it's got a little busy
here
um there's been six different winners in
seven races
and i believe fabio cuatro he was going
to make the podium he's going to be in
third place but he did
something i didn't figure out what it
was because i had to run out and do my
show so i
um so he got some sort of time penalty
uh so i think he got bumped down to
fourth place
and um i don't know i i just
i love that [ __ ] sport i really do
such a great thing
great thing to watch an easy thing to
watch there's 25 26 laps
you can knock it out but um let's get
back to uh real estate
here in connecticut i went on zillow
zillow's so [ __ ] awesome isn't it
don't you love going on there and just
having no limit
to the house that you could buy it's one
of my favorite things to do
or you see a [ __ ] house i do that a
lot you know if i go out i fly a heli
you know fly in the helicopter and i go
over like what the [ __ ] is that house
and then you go home you try to [ __ ]
zillow it see how much it cost
see what it looks like it's [ __ ]
amazing
so i've been doing that out here and um
i got to tell you like uh
i've kind of had this feeling that i've
wanted to do this for a while but like
my wife's a city kid uh and also just
you know having a racially mixed family
you kind of want to be in the city
people a little more [ __ ] open-minded
but i do have a uh
i would love to live in the middle of
[ __ ] nowhere not nowhere nowhere
you know just nowhere like i don't want
to be
you know on rural road 9 in the middle
of [ __ ] indiana
you know 40 [ __ ] 50 miles away from
the closest goddamn city i don't do that
[ __ ]
um that's when you run into ed gein when
you're [ __ ] that far out i don't want
to be [ __ ] doing that [ __ ] but i
wouldn't mind
you know living here in connecticut
being a good [ __ ]
just you know i don't give a [ __ ] about
the ocean the ocean scares the [ __ ] out
of me so i don't need any of that crap
you just get me near a lake i didn't
want to be on the lake just get me near
the [ __ ] lake
some [ __ ] house right a little
chicken coop in the back you know you
start
thinking that you could be like a farmer
or something
even though you grew up in the suburbs
you can barely make a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich you know
you could grow some [ __ ] tomatoes and
blah blah blah blah you're not gonna do
that
you're not you're gonna call the [ __ ]
geek squad of gardening
they're gonna come over and do the whole
[ __ ] thing then when you have a party
you're going to pretend like oh yeah we
harvested this
and this is some it's squash season
we made a squash soup it was just
absolutely
out of this world i'm telling you um
shout out to tampa bay lightning stamkos
coming back
comes in scores a goal and then leaves
in the second period he had the willis
reed game
um and the [ __ ] lightning take a two
to one lead i'm so bummed i missed the
game i've been uh
i watched all of game one and all of
game two and i really
was enjoying the match up uh i'm really
hoping that dallas comes back tonight
and ties it up
even though i think i'm just going to
miss it for the rest of the time because
i'm doing shows every single night which
is a [ __ ] awesome thing
and uh by the way i want to thank
everybody that's been coming out to my
shows and i was telling them you know
how uh
you know we're going to get past all of
this stuff we are
because that's what scientists do they
solve our problems
and uh but i was saying you know so
when we get past all this in the future
if somebody ever comes up to you and
says i am a hardcore
fan of stand-up comedy you get to go
really
did you sit on the side of a toboggan
hill on a farm in the middle of nowhere
in 40 degree [ __ ] weather
[Laughter]
um so i got to tell you speaking i'm
working with the great tony b
and joe bartnick the rose bowl tailgate
legend
and uh we're like a bunch of kids we're
just so [ __ ] excited to be back out
there performing for you guys
and it's such a wonderful thing
to be able to go back and do this [ __ ]
again and i'm actually enjoying that
rather than doing one big show i get to
do a bunch of shows
tightening up the act it's amazing how
quick it comes back you know
um i was like searching for the first
show and this
one and a half shows then i kind of got
my groove
the second show and last night the first
show i kind of took a little bit of a
step back
and then the second show i'm doing like
an
hour and i felt like i was on stage for
25 minutes or something and kenny gave
me the 50 minute light
and i was literally like get the [ __ ]
out i met up here for 50 minutes
one of those great shows just uh
riffing and doing my act and [ __ ]
around
and making fun of connecticut just i
don't know i've just been having a great
time so thank you to everybody who's
been coming out all right
let me read a little bit of uh advertise
in here
um what do we got
vincero oh vincero
vincero vincero i don't know what this
is uh you know you deserve
a watch that looks good makes you feel
good and doesn't break the bank
today's sponsor is vincero watches
vincero makes great looking watches for
under 200 bucks
and let me tell you let me tell you
something mcmahon uh these watchers are
not granddaddy's traditional of
um timepieces these are modern
sorry modern you can tell i've been
screaming for four shows
these are modern bold badass watches um
all at affordable prices vincero uh
vincero v-i-n-c-e-r-o
believes you deserve to look good and
feel good no matter your budget
i'm telling you i'm telling you right
now don't overpay for a watch that looks
cheap and disappoints
this is a timepiece you'll actually look
forward to putting on
there is a reason they have over 23
thousand
five star reviews on their website let
me say that again twenty three thousand
five star reviews on their website
plus they're offering free shipping and
free returns for 30 days and a warranty
on your watch for up to two years
it it really is stress-free risk-free
shopping
right from home no need to leave your
house uh the guys
over there sent some of their watches
and they really do look great uh that's
actually a true thing
they actually i usually don't even see
them but i i'm a watch guy they they do
look great the quality is definitely
there
you can feel right away you can feel it
right away when you're putting it on
you need to see these watches for
yourself if you need to just visit
www.vincerowatches.com
v-i-n-c-e-r-o to check them out
all right plus they are offering you as
listeners 20
off your entire order and they will
cover
all shipping costs if you visit
www.vincerowatches.com
with collections ranging from dress
ranging from dress watches to sports
watches to pilot watches
that's the one that sent me made me feel
like you know
made me feel like a [ __ ] stud
finchero has a style
for everyone for every look sorry
occasion and price point
they even have something for me the
altitude collection oh that's what they
sent me
uh that collection is vincero's modern
take on a pilot watch
it's bold it's sexy meow it's a watch i
would recommend to anyone because it's
so good looking so affordable they
actually send another one
um they actually sent another one from
their altitude collection for my pilot
instructor as well
i haven't given it to him yet but he's
going to love it uh
these are watches you will enjoy and
wear every single day if you don't
the channel will make it right all right
hey you got to make it right over here
all right that is their promise so go to
ventura watches v-i-n-c-e-r-o
watches dot com forward slash burr and
get and my discount code and use my
discount code
burr will automatically be applied at
checkout
do not pay full price on these bad boys
go to my link
pick out your favorite watch and get a
great discount right now this is the
easiest purchase you will make all year
oh my god look who's back everybody it's
all zip
monica starks could relate i love how
they do the personal stories now
monica starks could relate you guys she
needed to hire a piv
for a pivotal role at her construction
company
gs group but was having a tough time
finding the right person
especially with so many candidates out
there so she switched to all
[Music]
doesn't depend on candidates finding you
it finds them for you
it's technology identifies people with
the right experience for your job and
actively invites them
to apply which is why you should try zip
for free at ziprecruiter.com that's how
monica found
lamont you big dummy jenkins
monica found lamont jenkins she said
that zip recruiters sent lamont's
profile
to her around five minutes after she
posted her job
because he was a great match for the
role look at that you need to hire
somebody and within five minutes zip
recruiter can get back to you through
zip
monica's company has hired everyone from
accountants to project managers
to field scientists but monica is not
the only employer who loves zip
recruiter
four out of five employees who post on
zip
get a quality candidate within the first
day all right see for yourself how zip
recruiter makes hiring faster and easier
try right now for free that's right free
at ziprecruiter.com
that's it
dot com slash burr spell it out
z-i-p-r-e
b-u-r-r um what else we got we got two
more everybody hanging there oh
manscaped everybody hey yeah you [ __ ]
balls
hiding in a bush huh is your clam
buried down at the end of a hairy well
well we got manscaped here for you or
maybe this is just for guys i think it's
just for guys
why should a trimmer be gender specific
manscaped everybody do you have a moose
near the caboose
that needs to be tamed um i don't get
that a moose near the caboose the
caboose should be your ass do you have a
hairy ass is that what it is
i'm talking about hairy big
and needs some support what the [ __ ]
thankfully our sponsor manscape has you
covered to keep the hair looking nice
and trim and feeling fully supported
manscape offers precision engineered
tools for your family's jewels beluga
did you hear that that's your moose
asking for manscape
the manscaped engineering team just
perfected the greatest
ball hair trimmer ever the lawnmower 3.0
the premium lawnmower is waterproof so
you can
trim in the shower
it includes an led light so you can do
it in the dark you [ __ ] freak
um oh so if you're on a brokeback
mountain and you think you're going to
get
some action that night you're worried
that you got the [ __ ]
you know you got a [ __ ] little pube
puff down there you want to trim
down and it's made with advanced skin
safe tm
technology which reduces nicks and cuts
on your delicates
that's a big thing now you can get this
trimmer inside their perfect package 3.0
which also includes the manscape
proc crop preserver ball deodorant
and the crop reviver ball toning spray
jesus christ your balls are going to be
trimmed minty fresh
and have a tan like jfk when he [ __ ]
faced richard nixon back in 1960
both super practical and they smell
great too
plus for a limited time when you order
the perfect package kit
you get two free gifts the shed travel
bag and the manscaped anti-chafing boxer
briefs
uh the manscape boxer you know what i
swear to god manscape is going to do all
everything they can
to get rid of the time tested saying
dude i'm sweating my balls off they're
going to get rid of all of that
the manscape boxer briefs have optimal
temperature control
with their crop cooling technology while
keeping your pride and joy supported
pair these boxer briefs with the p8
their ph balancing liquid products like
the crop preserver
and you're ready for anything get 20 off
plus free shipping with the code bird
2.0
bird 20. sorry burr20 at manscape.com
your balls will thank you
get 20 percent off of free shipping with
the codebird20 manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
and use the
code bur 20 from the moose to the
caboose
always use the right tools for the job
yeah so the caboose is your ass okay
lastly but not leastly
policy genius everybody guess what we're
all gonna die
all right so don't you want to hook up
everybody around you with the biggest
keg party ever
with a nice life insurance policy right
september is national life insurance
awareness month
but with everything going on right now a
lot of people aren't even aware
if it's possible to buy life insurance
at all dude you remember that
breast cancer awareness in october that
the nfl used to be all about
how weird are those throwback games
gonna be like
when you see them all wearing pink now
that they don't do it anymore it's
[ __ ] hilarious
anyways the good news is that it's easy
to shop for life insurance right now and
if you
and your loved ones have loved ones
depending on your income
you probably should right now you could
save 1500 or more a year by using policy
genius to compare life insurance policy
uh when you're shopping for a policy
that could last
for a decade or more use savings those
savings really start to add up
what is policy genius it's an insurance
marketplace
built and backed by a team of industry
experts here's how it works
step one head to policygenius.com
in minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and compare quotes
from top insurers
to find your best price step two apply
for your lowest price
step three policy the policy genius team
will handle all your paperwork and red
tape
step four pour yourself a drink because
it's over policy genius works for you
not
not the insurance insurance company so
if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process they'll take care of
everything
they even have policies which are allow
eligible customers to skip the in-person
medical exam
and do it over the phone okay can you
reach down and grab your balls and turn
to the left and cough
how does that work um that kind are you
on facetime
wait wait wait lift your sack again i i
thought i saw something
uh that kind of service has earned
policy genius a five-star rating across
over 1600 reviews on trustpilot in
google
so if you need life insurance head to
policygenius.com
right now to get started you could save
fifteen hundred dollars or more by
comparing quotes on their marketplace
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right
hi we're policy genius is that how it's
supposed to end that sounds like that
should have been the beginning
high were policy geniuses at the end
that's [ __ ] weird um
anyways all right well that's the
podcast everybody i'm trying to think of
anything else
oh i've been out here with my uh i
brought the family out here and
everything we've been having a great
time
uh we went out to uh
lunch yesterday and dude i got to tell
you my daughter is so goddamn funny now
man
she's just the best she's just the best
and we've been really bonding because
i'm learning how to do her hair
oh freckles this morning out of french
braid
and uh she doesn't care she loves it
because she gets to watch like peppa pig
or
uh bugs bunny i can't believe it she's
into bugs bunny i actually you know
i did the old dad thing i was like well
here's a card because she's watching all
the new stuff she watches like
uh puppy dog pals
the harlan williams show um
she used to watch the uh
vampirina she hasn't watched that lately
paw patrol
um the one where there's the gekko
whatever the [ __ ] they are i don't know
that one and then i was just like i kind
of
slipped in sesame street the old school
ones
and uh bugs bunny and now she loves bugs
bunny
so now she walks around she goes yeah
what's up doc she does all of that
and uh it's the best so she gets to
watch those videos
while i'm when i'm doing doing her hair
it's the funniest [ __ ] ever i'm sitting
there doing her hair and she's
listening to like elmer fudd going i've
been working on the where whoa
[Laughter]
do you know someone was telling tony v
was telling me elmer fudd doesn't have a
gun anymore
it's like he's a hunter he didn't go in
and shoot up a [ __ ] school
i just don't understand
what the [ __ ] is that oh it's my
headphones i thought that was somebody
knocking i was turning and my headphone
was sliding off my ear really slowly
it sounded like somebody knocking um
anyway um what was i talking about
um yeah like the stuff that they do i
believe the cookie monster is back to
eating cookies again
it is just one of the dumbest things and
like really just
beyond censorship that the left has been
doing i cannot
as a lefty i just cannot [ __ ] believe
that we've we're we're name-calling
we're sense we're doing every [ __ ]
thing
that used to that the right used to do
we're ripping them off
we're a wannabe ac dc or whatever the
[ __ ] you want to call it
um hey by the way on the billbart
podcast we have this hilarious hashtag
that's uh it's not original i end up
finding out somebody else
at it but we sort of stumbled upon it
with little parallel thought it was uh
hashtag uh if i wasn't married and it
showed the stuff that you would buy and
the thing that i would have bought was
the
uh the uh gmc rv
with the palm desert green finish right
so everybody was showing that and
somebody showed this helicopter
um sent a picture of this helicopter uh
flight simulator that was incredible
and i literally saw i was like i want
that [ __ ] thing and
uh i went on the internet i tried to
find it i couldn't find it it had like a
wrap around
screen just like you have in a in
you know the panoramic view that you
have in a helicopter it had the stick it
had the whole thing
um i gotta try one of those out because
i just want to see like what a [ __ ]
auto rotation feels like in that
my autos are so [ __ ] from for my
skill level are so [ __ ] great right
now my favorite thing
is you know now is like if the low rpm
horn comes on
if i'm high enough i lower the
collective if i'm down low i just pull
back on the cyclic
to recover the rpms but when i'm up
higher in it and if you know
sometimes i haven't i have a habit of uh
having a nose up
attitude when i go into it so my my
speed slows down which eventually slows
down the rotor and i get into the
low rpm horn so then what would always
happen was i would lower the collective
like a [ __ ] lab rat the second you
hear that
that horrific sound you know
i would lower the collective which
obviously lows the nose
and uh your rpms come back up again and
i would never catch the rpms again
because it was too much it was too
overwhelming too many things trim
airspeed rpm too much [ __ ] ground coming
up to look at
but now the more you do them the more
you're sort of in the moment
and everything slows down and now i can
i getting to the point
i'm getting to the point where i can
feel the rpms going up and i just sort
of catch them as they go back up so
there's no worry about me
uh overspeeding the main rotor and all
of that
and i actually watched this there's this
one for the cabrille
g2 the helicopter that i want to get
uh someday that uh
this kid i should really post it i
should post that [ __ ] video
because this kid does this this auto
rotation right
and you know for all those people that
you know talk about oh my god you know
if it's an engine failure what do you do
in a helicopter just watch what this kid
does
it's so amazing because he sees his spot
right he's doing a uh
you know he's doing an auto auto like a
like
practicing it it's not like he actually
had a real engine failure
so he sees his spot he realizes he's
going to overshoot it and there's a
number of things that you can do and
what he decides to do
is he literally does like a big
like 360 and he adds like an s turn
so what he's doing is he's just
adding you know rather than going
directly to the spot he's sort of
like serpentine into it so you're losing
all of this altitude as you're doing it
and he has it figured out where he knows
where he needs to be so when he comes
out of the s turn and he comes all the
way back around again basically did a
360.
he's now lined up with his spot comes
right in
goes into the flare and just lands it
like a daisy and it's uh
it was so inspiring to watch that but
also knowing that i can do it
i can do 80 of that my thing in the end
is um i don't hope this doesn't bore you
but there's there's a habit that's a
sort of a natural thing they do that as
you see the ground coming up
you pull back on the stick it's it's
just sort of this natural reaction
even though the most subtle thing and
what that does
is it actually sort of begins your flair
earlier it can bleed off your [ __ ]
air speed and everything so what you
have to do is you got to train yourself
to look long
and uh i just had gotten into that
you know before i went on this trip so i
can't wait to come back and get to that
thing and i'm literally gonna get to the
point
where i'm gonna be able to do it as good
as that kid and then when i go out with
my instructor
i'm just gonna be like okay on this
whole [ __ ]
flight just chop throttle whenever you
want to and i have to pick a spot and
then it just becomes muscle memory and
then for my entire time
of flying just like once a week i'm
going to go up with this guy
and just do like you know 10 15 [ __ ]
auto rotations
all different kinds you know right above
the spot
um you're too far away from the spot
that's another great one
where you can then you actually
fly in the upper register of
the low rpm horn coming on so you can
still
maintain your rpms but you're listening
to the horn on the let's like
the alarms on the entire time um
there's other things that you do you can
come in and if you're coming in you're
going to overshoot your spot
you turn the thing sideways the
helicopter sideways which adds all this
drag
and then your pitot tube's not pointing
into the wind so your air speed starts
coming down which freaks you out the
first time because you're thinking like
oh my god i'm going too slow i'm going
to lose my [ __ ] rpms
and that's literally not what's
happening the whole it's the most
fascinating [ __ ] thing
ever and someone like me who had such a
poor science background
now understanding the physics of all
that it's one of the coolest [ __ ]
things ever so
that's my nerd now helicopter [ __ ] you
know i've nerded out about [ __ ] drums
and all of that stuff
um oh by the way um this will be a
little bit longer today
let's talk music here one of my other
favorite [ __ ] things i have uh
ah [ __ ] i don't have my phone with me so
i'm not gonna remember the guy's name i
sort of stumbled upon this guy
this guitar player [ __ ] how do i get to
it
the [ __ ] is the guy's name i want to say
it begin with the t
ah god damn it remind me i'll tell you
he's sort of like you know
obviously heavily heavily heavily
heavily influenced
by uh jimi hendrix his last name begins
with the t
i believe i just don't know what his
first [ __ ] name is
ah [ __ ] i think it was tr something
derek trucks drive by truckers
john mayo trio that's none of that
oh come on i'm not going to be able to
find it god damn it
anyways i've been listening to to that
album
and arrow smith's first album which i
absolutely love because
it's like two albums before they broke
they broke
nationally i believe on toys in the
attic
so um when with each album they got a
little bigger and they would expand the
circle where they could tour and sell
tickets just like a comic anybody else
trying to sell
tickets on the road but their first
album you could tell
like you know they put their money
together maybe somebody backed him a
little bit but it's really
raw and uh moving out
somebody obviously dream on
which literally became a hit like like
two three years after they put it out oh
by the way shout out to the great joe
perry
um just had a birthday 70 years young
um
and what else yeah so i just been going
on walks out here
like an old man breathing in this fresh
air looking at all these beautiful farms
out here i hope you people out here on
the east coast you really understand
how [ __ ] gorgeous where you live is
after [ __ ] being out there with the
fires but i will tell you i'm not
you know [ __ ] on california because
i absolutely love it out there too
um which is something you learn how to
do when you travel after a while
it's like you don't try to do what the
[ __ ] you do
at home you figure out what people do
where you're now at
and you [ __ ] jump in with both feet
you know it's a [ __ ] mistake i used
to do a bit about that when i first
moved to [ __ ]
la you know i tried to be the new york
east coast guy
boston guy you know wearing my
three-quarter leather leaning into my
accent
you know trying to hang on to this
[ __ ] [ __ ] rather than just going
on a hike and getting a burrito
i was bitching about their pizza so
[ __ ] stupid i actually
lived i lived in a [ __ ] apartment
that was a five-minute walk to one of
the great
hikes in hollywood is it runyon canyon i
don't know what you call it
and i didn't even i was there for eight
months
and didn't even know it was there that's
how much i was not [ __ ] trying to
check out [ __ ] when i was living in la
and um
this comic came out to stay with me for
pilot season when i used to have pilot
season and i remember she
uh she went out to get a coffee
and [ __ ] the first day she's like hey
do you know there's like a [ __ ]
amazing park right now i was like no
she was like we should go do that and
like the next day we went out and did it
and i was just like holy [ __ ] and we did
it like
every day it was funny neither one of us
booked a pilot and um
but we did go hiking every day
so anyways i know what the [ __ ] i'm just
babbling at this point uh because i'm in
a great mood because i'm doing shows
again and i'm working
making a little bit of money here
finally in 2020 uh
thank god for the podcast and you guys
listening because you guys have been
keeping me afloat here
so that's it that's the podcast uh enjoy
the music from the great andrew females
and we have a bonus episode of
a past thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast
go celtics hang in there i didn't see
the game
but i can tell that you know miami just
[ __ ] would not go away even though we
had a lead they just [ __ ] ran us down
but uh as much as it sucks if we do lose
to miami not make the finals
i think this um this
the young celtics watching the more
experienced miami heat
the way that they play it rubs off on
you you learn
how to win by losing to winners
and miami is playing like a bunch of
winners man and i cannot i can't get mad
at it they're just playing [ __ ] great
they're really playing great but i'm
also excited for the uh the future
of the young celtics all right that's it
go [ __ ] yourselves
have a great weekend i'll talk to you on
monday okay i almost forgot
um stay tuned for my call into the
sports gambling podcast
coming up right after the music break i
do all my picks for the nfl
by the way old freckles is four and one
so far this year
so now that i said that i'll probably go
off the rails but listen to it after the
music okay
bill burr on the sports gaming podcast
is brought to you by mybookie.ag
head over to mybookie.ed to get in on
all the nfl action and use the promo
code bur
for a 100 deposit bonus that's my
bookie.ag promo code burr
joining us on the line bill burr bill
coming off a red hot four and one run
against the spread
in the nfl how was your uh how was your
football sunday
my football sunday was awesome i uh
i watched a bunch of games i watched a
little bit of uh
buffalo as a patriots fan this this
wasn't josh allen the guy's throwing
like
300 something yards 400 yards you guys
then he's leading the league in yards so
i'm excited for long-suffering buffalo
fans
um but i'm also you know i think it's
kind of cool though that
you know it's to see how bella check
with cam newton and all these new guys
how we match up and i know that that's
going to be a great game whenever that
game comes up because uh
you know we've been getting the best of
them for a while so i know that
they can't wait to beat us so i watched
a little bit of that
i watched lamar jackson desean watson i
watched a little bit of that in the
ravens texans
i watched the surprising san diego
charger game
yeah that was a fun one that was amazing
that was a fun one
i missed the overtime you know i got
kids and stuff so i was dipping in and
out of that and then i watched a little
bit of the
uh the raiders with their incredible new
stadium
that stadium looks amazing uh against
uh who did they play the saints yeah i
enjoyed all of those games
i just kind of lucked out and uh i also
watched a little bit of jacksonville and
uh
tennessee was it tennessee yeah i think
it was tennessee
yeah no it's watched a lot it's
interesting too i mean the big concern
coming into the season was like oh they
don't have pre-season the games are
going to be sloppy it's going to be ugly
but
i i mean i think overall the the quality
of play i mean
with the exception of uh my eagles
looking like dog [ __ ]
most of the i think overall the league
has looked pretty solid
i mean it was an exciting day injuries
aside there were there were good games
as bill was pointing out and and
dramatic ending
oh cisco got destroyed those i mean
who they they lost it bosses is that
impossible garoppolo
it's a bunch of people man that's uh but
i will say though you know i bet the nfl
players union is definitely going to be
lobbying for
at least one less pre-season game
because
it's just it's just the nature of
football you can't go out and play it
light and there's people
you know if you're like a start and you
know you're going to make the team and
you're lining up against some guy who's
trying to make the team it's like
you kind of have to play a real game
even if it's just for a quarter
and the amount of money and what's on
the line and just also the
collateral damage of years of banging
heads
what is the point is probably going to
be their argument well yeah i mean it is
it is crazy and they even kind of hit on
it in hard knocks like these guys at the
edge of the roster kind of on the bubble
it's like
you're lining up against a guy he has a
chance to make like crazy money
for his family that he may never have
the opportunity again
against the guy who's just like looking
to get five snaps and get out of the
game like
the difference in sort of energy and
what you're bringing it just
it just seems like it could lead to a
ton more injuries
i got a pitch for them they should they
should call them the bubble games
and you got you have a feel you rock 11
people on both sides that are on the
bubble whether they're going to make it
or not
and it becomes like survivor like who's
going to uh who's like a reality show
it'd be way more interesting as opposed
to people going like well you know
brady's just going to play like you know
like two drives or whatever a couple of
snaps and it's going to be over and then
who cares
it's actually could be like a really
interesting like
maybe would make it more dramatic i'm
sure the veterans
would not care yeah no who who votes no
right like this is the the hypothetical
who votes no here the guy's trying to
make the roster like it the coaches like
it because they get to coach football
and the vets are like hell yeah sign me
up i don't need to play this game
well yeah and that's kind of what people
like about the college game they like
that these guys aren't
you know the millionaires with like
making business decisions out there
that's usually kind of the knock
and uh i mean that's the appeal of the
college like there's i mean granted some
of these guys are clearly getting paid
under the table
but uh the the purity and then and kind
of the i don't know the home rivalry and
everything
it is is certainly they're not old
enough to realize they don't have to
work hard yeah you know what i mean
they haven't they haven't been tainted
by the money yet uh but we actually got
some uh
college football kicking off this week
big game or at least uh especially for
the show here
coach oh coach uh coach o who we've
always rooted for and then coach leach
who
is a regular calling into our podcast so
we're taking mississippi state
getting 16 and a half points but lsu
former national champions obviously they
lost a bunch of players
and uh offensive coordinator to the pros
are you gonna be watching this game
saturday bill
any thoughts you know lsu was my team i
started watching them way back in the
day
the coach's name escapes me i just lost
his name in my i'm
old now let's go beat the grass oh no
coach
yeah oh my god the mad hatter
he was fun he was yeah he would he used
to coach some games like the
you know the upper deck so he's like go
for it fake field goal like he did all
of that stuff he was really fun
the problem when he coached was they
never had a quarterback
and they did that stupid thing where it
was just like oh
it's a running play let's put the black
quarterback in it's a passing play let's
throw the white quarterback and neither
guy could get in a rhythm
or or anything so i really felt that
that hurt them for a long time so when
when edo got in there um
and you know they got joe burrow from uh
ohio state show you how loaded they are
that guy couldn't get time
um and now seeing what he's doing with
cincinnati looking like a second
third year guy already um i'm a huge lsu
guy
and and joe burrows killing it that
running back there with the 20 names
there for kc's doing great as a
defensive back for jacksonville
was lighting people up that went to lsu
too
so uh it's a good look for them but
haven't said that
16 and a half points is it at home
yeah it's at at lsu laying 16 and a half
i mean again i i'm big on the lsu
program but
you know coach leach with that air raid
i think they'll get enough to cover the
16 and a half
i think so too and with the new
quarterback new system new guys i don't
know what their running game looks like
that's a lot of points to put up with i
would take mississippi state
you can't just rep i mean a lot of guys
playing on sunday who just came off that
team so
yeah a good fade opportunity crazy
amount of uh pros
yeah left the roster and now you gotta
play against the air raid i don't know
it's always kind of tricky
but uh getting back to your patriots
they're at home laying six points
against the raiders raiders obviously
coming off that huge monday night win
at home against the saints now they got
to go up to new england
as a better i always like taking
belichick
after a loss are you are you uh
optimistic
to pats take care of business here where
are you at with the patriots this week
yeah i know i like the patriots this
week because
i thought they looked twice as good as
they looked
against the dolphins and i don't think
that they're going to be one of those
teams that plays to their competition
because of coach belichick
so um the fact that we were able to
compete with seattle who just you know
you got to give pete carroll the the
draft picks
he just gets like defensive players that
just really light people up
and uh i and and russell wilson is just
i mean that guy
he i still think the guy is underrated i
think he could play way up in that
corner you just don't get the shine of
playing in
other football markets but the fact that
we were able to be that competitive
against them
the fact that i wasn't watching cam
newton running all around the fact that
byrd and harry
also got you know harry had like eight
catches and opened it up for edelman
adam had like a career game at like
almost 180 yards
um but the only thing that worries me
because we're protecting cam well
our running game is still anemic um
but uh what's his face you know oh god
i'm too old with the names i know he
just lost
uh his poor guy lost his mom and a trx
james wasn't
able to play yeah i mean god what a
phone call to get off oh jesus
um i'm hoping we can get our running
game
going and um but i mean i know his dad's
still in critical condition that's just
a lot to ask
for someone to then go out and go play
football and all that when your mind's
gonna be somewhere else but i still like
the patriots at home
i thought um going up against like the
unsolvable problem of russell
wilson we played him really really well
we played you know
the receivers well it's just the they
just right now that they
were a better team so but i like us at
home i don't mind giving six points
derek carr a very solvable problem
belichick will have that one figured out
and
and i got to imagine that uh in games
following a
massive bear hug of john gruden and make
mike mayheck don't go well for the
raiders
i suppose i mean gee this is just the
ultimate time to bet well yeah
and you watch them monday night it
looked like they won the super bowl like
if there was
if there was a tub of gatorade and they
could pour it on them
you know i'm sure it violates a bunch of
coved rules or whatever they would have
done that
it had that feeling you know jacked up
first game in the new stadium
and now you're going up to new england
new england coming off a loss they're
going to be
firing on all cylinders possibly the
yeah i think but troon's gone through a
lot i love gruden and
he went through like he that they he
picked that team up from the ashes so
they i i don't think that they overly
celebrated they needed that
they really needed that win that was
great for them their franchise
the whole new location everything so i
think it's going to be a tough game
but i still think we pull it out and
beat him by uh i think we'll beat him by
more than six
yeah i mean again for me it's all about
belichick coming off a loss
he's gonna have those guys ready to go
especially at home
possibly game of the week monday night
ravens
three and a half point favorites against
the kansas city
chiefs uh to me it seems crazy to give
the
the kansas city chiefs points but again
how do you go against this ravens team
right now they've looked unstoppable
both games
granted cleveland and uh houston's
defense hasn't looked amazing but
i i don't know what which uh which side
are you leaning here bill
is the game in baltimore yep they're at
home laying three and a half monday
night they're i mean
should be a great game yeah
oh man and it's early in the season i i
actually you i don't know much about the
ravens defense
i don't uh pretty good this year
yeah i think though there's something
about kansas city where they wear you
down and you think you got them
and then they just i don't know
somewhere late in the third quarter
like they just start clicking and you
know when you think you're shutting
everybody down and then all of a sudden
they just start going like uh
i i think i i'm gonna take kansas city
with the points
smart man not often you get to get
points with patrick mahomes
yeah you're getting points with patrick
mahomes i mean again
i'm kind of scared to favor the ravens
but again the chiefs shouldn't be
getting three and a half points like
they
we've just saw them go off on like a
historic run the end last season can't
you see the stupid espn animations with
patrick mahomes throwing five touchdowns
like
mortar shells yeah i just think also
patrick mahomes is a big game guy and
the fact that it's on monday night he
knows the other players in the league
are probably watching the game
checking it out i just think that the
bigger the game the better the stars
played no disrespect obviously
to lamar jackson the guy's incredible
but i just think
uh that that they i think they're going
to have too many weapons the game's too
long i saw it last year as a patriots
fan you can contain those guys for only
so long and then they just
they just i don't know they just the
ball starts getting rolling and then
it gets it can get ugly quick against
those guys and i just think monday night
football
you know mahomes is a stud and he's
gonna he's gonna deliver
yeah i know i mean it definitely seems
like they kind of have that fast break
almost like a basketball style golden
state warriors type where
once they start hitting a couple threes
they get that momentum the muscle memory
the guys just start firing on all
cylinders and
especially if you give andy reid like an
extra day to prepare
again it's no knock on the ravens or
harbaugh but
yeah lay given that extra half a point
maybe that could be key
but yeah chiefs plus three and a half
seems to be the way to go
all right bill before we let you go here
any uh any big
season takeaways from now until the end
of the season any
any predictions uh you have just i know
small sample size we've only
seen two games so far any big thoughts
for
uh from now until the end of the season
i gotta be honest with you i am so
excited
that they're just playing the games i'm
enjoying
the nhl playoffs i'm watching the nba
i'm doing all of that i
i'm just so excited to play in the games
i i'm almost like living in the moment
so i haven't even thought
beyond week two forget about three i i
have no idea in the nfl you know there's
so many good teams there's so many good
new quarterbacks coming out and all of
that type of stuff that
i i don't um i don't think two weeks in
you can really see
um any sort of like yeah these guys i
think they have what it takes you know
that's why it's so hard to gamble in
september it's probably why i'm
four and one just it's just not a dumb
luck believe me
my professional handicapped in october
no by mid mid-october people are going
to stop listening to me
well this is i mean and this is you hear
that shawn coach speak
one game at a time i like that but you
didn't fall for the trap it's all about
the next game
see that's how good belichick is even
the patriots fans know
we're taking it one game at a time we
don't want to look past
to october where that's the that's part
of the brilliance of bill belichick they
all think the guy's a boring guy he
isn't
he knows what people do in the media
they're gonna take anything that he says
and and try to turn it into bullet and
board material so he gives
short quick answers and just compliments
the other team
and people and then people just take it
at face value he's already playing the
game when he's talking to people in
sports media
and people think that this guy doesn't
put a lampshade on his head after a
couple shots of tequila i know he does
yeah you know he does he's not gonna do
it at a press conference
yeah you've seen the shots of him like
hanging out with his uh
girlfriend or wife at the time and he's
out out on some yacht
in florida like you don't think that
guy's having a good time he realizes
he's talking trash he's having a great
time you know he is
you don't think that guy has a couple
shots and brings up the fact that he won
five super bowls how would you not these
guys are if you regardless of where you
are
live did you just say five you forgot
the 66.
oh wait you're right because he wants
yeah he won some with the bills
was i said that he was going to shut
down the ramps because
i already knew he shut down john elway
in 86
and he shut down jim kelly and all those
lunatics in 1990. he's built an entire
career
on shutting down high powered up he
owned the colts and peyton manning with
their three-headed monster he owned
those guys
this is that's what this guy does he's
the greatest defensive mind
he's the modern-day paul brown i'm
telling you
yeah no looking back in hindsight sean
mcveigh didn't have a chance
like you're gonna bring jared goff
against uh bill belichick who's just
salivating having two weeks to prepare
how to shut him down spider in a butter
knife to a [ __ ] war
dude forget about that what about what
about mike marks playing into the
patriots
oh my god and they thought they didn't
even use marshall [ __ ] it was one of the
stupidest things i've ever seen in my
life
yeah i mean really you could make a case
that first super bowl with brady
coming off the bench and making that run
that was possibly
some of the greatest coaching run of all
the great great offenses hey guess who
was at that game
oh wait you were you were at that first
super bowl
i went to the one where we lost to the
packers and then i
when i went when we beat the rams and
i said i was going to go every time the
patriots went to the super bowl
and then the next time they went i think
it was against carolina
i was doing the world series the dice
sketch
was a chappelle show was shooting
first one out of the gate on monday
mornings the first time i met the late
great charlie murphy
and i was so bummed i couldn't go to the
game but obviously psyched to be on the
chappelle show and i just remembered at
the end of the game
when we won and i still had you know
back then it cost about fifteen hundred
two grand to go
and when i still had that money in my
pocket and i didn't have to get on a
plane
and i really looked back and i said you
know i won the i watched the first one
they ever won
i was there with my my older brother and
my dad it's not going to get better than
that oh yeah
um and then i i didn't go to another one
um
i haven't gone to one sense and and i i
you know i i i had the experience let
some other pats fan get the tickets
somebody else or whatever and i'm and i
always if i ever go again i'm you know
you
you have to sit in the crowd man you
can't you can't be up there in the
stupid one of those boxes it's just like
you feel like you're watching it at home
while you're there
i hate those things yeah i mean that's
well and also i mean that's an all-time
life i mean that's like a awesome
problem to have hey i can't go to the
super bowl to watch my team
i'm i'm working on the chappelle show
that that must have been
i know right crimea rivers no no i'm
just saying that's a
that's a great thing they won the game
too so yeah it worked out it all worked
out
you certainly yeah i mean to be on the
other side of that
well bill appreciate you calling in as
always man uh thanks a lot and uh best
of luck with the picks this weekend
okay the only one i'm really you know
it's always the pass i just want the
pats to win
go pats all right guys thanks man i'll
see you
thanks for checking out the sports
gaming podcast make sure you subscribe
to our podcast to hear us pick
every nfl game against the spread and
give us a follow on twitter at
gamblingpodcast
and of course if you want to play win
and get paid go to mybookie.edu
promo code burr
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday september 24th
2012. what's going on how are you
how's your little monday doing where are
you
at work you sitting in a cubicle you're
on a treadmill
did you call in sick did you do that
did you have the right sound in your
voice yeah hey
it's michael uh i i don't know what
happened you know last night i wasn't
feeling so good
uh you know you just [ __ ] hear
yourself go what am i doing
i can't just be like hey this is michael
listen um that job is [ __ ] sucking
the soul out of me but i don't have any
other financial options so
you know i'm gonna keep working there
but not today how about that
all right go [ __ ] yourself i'll see on
tuesday
that'd be great if you could just be
that honest and still somehow earn a
living
you know somehow [ __ ] still be asked
to come to work the next day
uh michael can you come in here uh we
some concerns about
some of the insubordinate comments that
you made
what does that word even [ __ ] mean
does insubordinate mean independent
thoughts
is that what it is some of your thoughts
that are outside the
you know the thoughts that we told you
to have you're not having anymore and
that that concerns us
you were always a guy who was thinking
um what we were telling you to think in
the past and suddenly you're not and
that concerns us
and that concerns us so just let you
know you just went from the yellow list
over to the blue list
and the next list is the red list and
those people go first
what's that i'm talking about fema camps
yes i am um
that's something i looked up reading
about those [ __ ] lists that they have
i wasn't i wasn't [ __ ] reading about
them did i read about them i just
watched a couple of youtube videos about
it you know what's funny about the
[ __ ] new world order you know what
makes me chuckle about it
is it's completely on paper
it's totally [ __ ] necessary
i have come full circle i understand why
i'm going to be eliminated so if anybody
in a [ __ ] hood
a cloaked hood or whatever you know if
you're listening in while you're
dripping [ __ ] hot wax on a goddamn
maltese falcon whatever the [ __ ] you're
doing in your weird ass little ritual
i i don't need to be re-educated i get
it
just get on with the killing
you know i'll be the only guy going to a
death camp like playing a banjo
you know with the folk tune called i get
it
[Laughter]
um no i seriously you know i was reading
all this [ __ ] about you know how
in the u.n they're finally addressing
talking about the population problem
and a lot of people are coming up with
this [ __ ] where they're just like look
we got to get
rid of 90 of the population
you know and to do it in a way
that like you know
doesn't make every other [ __ ]
genocide like look
what am i trying to say here the only
way you can [ __ ] do that
what am i trying to [ __ ] say here
jesus christ okay so thanks go all right
if everybody just has one kid from here
on out we can get the population down
to like three and a half billion by 2075
but i but the problem is is like most
things we just treated it like a term
paper it's too [ __ ] late
so you got other people like oh no we
got a [ __ ] you know
you got the other people they're acting
like you know the host of that hoarder
show where they're just like throw it
all out it's all [ __ ] right i think that
that's what they're gonna do
so i guess if you want to survive what
you have to do is you gotta up what you
bring into the game
you know because if you're like me and
you're kind of like the human equivalent
to a stack of newspapers with the dead
cat underneath it
you know that you you're going to be uh
you're going to be go you're going to be
out the [ __ ] window
all right i wonder if they're gonna let
you choose how you wanna die
how would you do it
you know what do i do you know what i
would like i would like to [ __ ] be on
some sort of
bungee cord that goes [ __ ] instead of
up and down it goes side to side
and i just swing on it they they bring
me back oh i go rub i'll go a giant
slingshot
and just get shot into that giant tv at
uh cowboys game doing like a monday
night football game
you know knowing that i'm gonna die but
i set it up like it's gonna be this
stunt where i'm gonna go over it
you know and i just horrify some kids
that'll be like my last thing is i
bounce off that turf
right next to tony romo i'm sorry people
i've been alone all [ __ ] week this is
the [ __ ] i'm thinking about this is the
monday morning podcast everybody this is
the uplifting
mmp talking about eliminating 90
of the people the world's population as
you sit there eating a [ __ ] eclair
huh
who had one already who already had a
[ __ ] eclair this week
huh who honey why don't we really
declare
who eats a [ __ ] eclair you know what
i mean
with that [ __ ] goddamn jizz in the
middle of it i mean if like it wasn't
disgusting enough
you got to get like a donut facial
that's got to be like one of the you
know like the low points when you just
have like total
like just self-hatred i would think as a
fat person if you just bought a dozen
eclairs
when you're polishing off like the
eighth or ninth one if you had a big
fuzzy beard it's all in your mustache
and you look like you're in some donut
[ __ ] movie you just gotta you just
he's gotta be like what
what happened you know i used to climb
trees
i used to do cartwheels um
i'm going back to la tomorrow man i had
a great week at caroline's
i want to thank everybody got two more
shows i'm recording this uh sunday
afternoon before i do my final two shows
as you notice my voice is a little
froggy you know from screaming like a
jackass all week
the problem is is i have the sensation
opening up for me
and you know the way he screams as a
feature act i have to go there as a
headliner
and i have to yell even more um you know
we've been having a real good time this
week giving each other [ __ ] about each
other's acts
the stuff we don't like about it and
both of our acts got better
you know our friendship suffered a
little bit on a creative level but i
think at the end of the day it's a nice
thing
i know what a lot of you guys are
thinking why didn't you just have joe
come over and do the [ __ ] podcast
ah because we drank until five in the
morning that's why
okay and just out of a common courtesy
you know friend a friend when you drink
with somebody till five in the morning
you don't ask them to drag their ass out
of bed
and come in onto your podcast for
absolutely no [ __ ] money
do you know what i mean although i bet
if i put a couple of eclairs down
i bet joe would show up you know
oh [ __ ] shoeless joe all right
what else [ __ ] goddamn jets one
i don't have a tv so i have no [ __ ]
idea i didn't watch it looks like the
dolphins blew that one so that they're
two and one
i figure by the time you hear this the
patriots will be one and two
i don't know the patriots are gonna be
one of those teams you know that those
jerk offs on espn will be like you know
i'll tell you i thought the patriots
then i got to be thinking
which team's gonna be showing up
tomorrow i mean
look at the stats first week i mean the
scoring like 48 points
went up 17. are you thinking okay shut
up
you [ __ ] nerd you know you know what
i want
i want well-spoken people who actually
played the game
to tell me what i should be thinking i
don't want to listen to somebody who
went to [ __ ] journalism school
all right and was in chess club telling
me what what
what tom brady's got to be thinking you
know what i mean
i'm [ __ ] grumpy um i don't even know
what's going on
i went to a [ __ ] football game last
week so i missed the patriots blow it
against tampa bay i still have that on
my dvr
you like that echo in this apartment the
sparsely furnace department i have
you know what's great about an echo in a
room it makes it just makes you feel
like you're addressing a bunch of people
ask not what your country could do for
you
you know i think i could give one of
those political speeches
one of those rah-rah things today
america is at a crossroads
if you look back at our history this
country has been defined by the choices
that we have made when we have reached
the crossroads
it takes strength takes courage
takes conviction
but i believe
that i felt if
he's just sitting there staring at their
shoes
waiting for that [ __ ] moment where
they know they're supposed to clap
that i feel that we can rise above
today's challenges and we will
because that's what america is made up
and everybody
starts [ __ ] clapping and then you're
sitting there going all right that's
good that's good i got through the first
of the speech nobody's taking a shot at
me so i haven't pissed off the looney
birds
or the people who employ me right
i haven't pissed off the bankers of the
corporations and i even
pissed off [ __ ] eddie earl [ __ ]
johnson from east mississippi
who's coming up here with this handmade
[ __ ] glock
isn't that what rednecks do aren't they
just sitting around or
whittling whittling all day you know
with their [ __ ] weapons
you know something guns are like the
comic book
for like uh for like rednecks you like
nerds are always into like they have
like a comic book collection
like anthony kumia from the wonderful on
a program he's like a comic book nerd
except he's
he's into guns and instead of talking
about whether the hulk could be
captain america he talks about oh the
lovely nia everybody hang on
hey nia hey i'm almost done recording
the podcast let me call you right back
bye-bye see that that was a little white
lie
i'm not almost done i'm only [ __ ] 10
minutes in that's what you got to do
that's what you got to do to keep a
relationship going you know you don't
tell big lies but a bunch of little ones
i'm going to be there in five minutes
how many times you tell that why
hmm absolutely
yes i was listening to you well you
you were talking about how your mom i
don't know why you're [ __ ] coming at
me right
we've all done that [ __ ] you know what i
did this morning this is how much of a
[ __ ] sports nerd i am
i just wrote down all the [ __ ] teams
that i've seen
people seem to be interested in that
other well who's kid who other [ __ ]
sports nerds
um what the hell is it here
i only need to see four more
professional teams 14 more
and i'm done i've seen all the [ __ ]
baseball teams
i've seen all but five right all but
four football teams and i'm gonna see
three of them in the next [ __ ] month
or so
so i'll have one more there hockey i got
three more to see
ottawa the hurricanes and the lightning
otherwise known as o g and z
who the [ __ ] wants to go to any of those
places ottawa
huh you're halfway to toronto
[Music]
um
the hurricanes and the lightning that's
just that's that's not gonna happen
and then basketball i got the dirty
south i don't know when the [ __ ] i'm
gonna see have the grizzlies the bobcats
the [ __ ] magic i never go down south
right the hornets
got the spurs and the suns and then the
raptors
really i'm gonna go all the way to
toronto to go see a [ __ ] cba team
these last few are going to be rough
they're going to be rough
and um i wonder what's going to happen
when i finally complete this goal
am i going to high-five myself for going
to all these events by myself isn't it
rather sad when you think about it even
nerds when they go to the [ __ ] comic
cons
they got someone to go with right
drive next to each sit next to each
other as they drive down to the [ __ ]
thing
um all right let's do a little
advertising shall we people
so i'm starting to [ __ ] sweat here i
had to open a window
i hope i'm not being too goddamn loud
what are they gonna do
huh yell at me hey
[ __ ] keep it down yeah you [ __ ]
keep it down um stamps.com everybody
would you like to bring the post office
into your apartment into your house into
your dwelling wouldn't that be great
who's getting who going to the post
office sure you see other people
you know you listen to their dumb
stories about what their kids doing you
don't care
you don't care about that kid you
probably think that kid's ugly
right why do you want to go down and
listen to that dumb stories
run into that person who's sitting there
you know you haven't seen him since high
school why wouldn't it be great if you
could just stay in your own place where
you live
just print out your own steps what if
you got a little scale you could
oh i want to put something in a box and
you just weigh it right
you put a little stamp on it you take it
out to the post office
and you tell that psycho to pick the
damn thing up and take it back to the
place where it works then you're done
wouldn't that be awesome well listen you
can do that with stamps.com you can buy
and print us official us postage
using your own computer and printer you
can get the postage for any letter or
package whenever you need it 24
7. you can do it at four in the morning
you can do it at 11 o'clock
uh then just hand it over to your
mailman just like i said and you'll
never have to go to the post office
again
okay that's it um it's great for small
business homes offices and people like
me that use stamps.com to send out
dvds to my fans provided there's some
available
whole different story it saves me time
money and makes my life easier
right now use my last name bur burr for
this special offer no risk trial
plus 110 bonus offer that includes a
digital scale and up to 55 dollars free
postage
don't wait go to stamps.com before you
do anything else
put down that eclair click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in burr
b-u-r-r uh that's burr
snaps.com sorry i just got distracted by
the phone
so anyways back to the goddamn podcast
here sorry
i'll show you how to take that [ __ ]
phone call but through the wonder of the
pause button
um i can't wait to get the [ __ ] out of
new york
i got to tell you something this i i i
can't stay in shape
in this [ __ ] city especially when
you're going out goddamn drinking and
then you [ __ ] walk home and you get
the slice of pizza
or a [ __ ] goddamn bacon egg and
cheese
you know it's amazing that everybody in
this city doesn't weigh
nine zillion pounds i guess because you
walk around so much
you know i don't know i have to give a
shout out to the uh
sort of like dictator light that they
have here um what's his name bloomberg
you know that guy you know who legally
you can only have two terms and somehow
he got around it and he's in his [ __ ]
third term
basically he's gonna leave he's gonna
step down being mayor when he's goddamn
ready this [ __ ]
he's taken away he puts seats in the
middle of the street
in times square he did it down near
macy's
the old herald square right
right herald square and uh and then on
all these other [ __ ] streets he just
lets people kind of park the in the
second lane over from the curb and then
the other lane is like a bike lane
i guess he just doesn't want people
driving around anymore
either that or he's aware that the world
population is going to be reduced
by 90 percent and he's getting the jump
just going like well we don't need all
these [ __ ] lanes
[Laughter]
you don't need all this [ __ ] you know
we just put some seats we'll put some
sun chairs right in the middle of
[ __ ] times square
maybe you know something maybe he's
trying to warn us
you know but if he warns us they're
going to kill his entire family so these
are the little hints that he's giving us
these little things he used his [ __ ]
money to stay in office to give us the
hint that the uh
the extermination is coming right
see this is this is why nia is so good
for me and having a dog when i'm around
people and i you know
you just have you have great thoughts
this is how you become the unabomber
you just [ __ ] hang out with yourself
it only takes a good eight days
eight days you slowly go nuts
you start you just start thinking about
uh
i don't know what you think about you
think about dying
thinking about that [ __ ] this is just
this is [ __ ] depressing
you know it'd be great if i watched some
football i could talk about that i have
absolutely nothing to talk about
i can just riff about the [ __ ] bare
walls in my [ __ ] apartment here
do you guys be upset with me if i just
broke down and started crying here on
the podcast
would you do that oh here's something
for you my agent came by with some of
the cities i'm going to be performing in
next
year next year baby
would you like to hear them would you
like a list of some of them
i got let me let me see if there's some
here that i've uh
haven't been to in a while what do we
got here
and i've been to all of these [ __ ]
cities oh i'm finally maybe gonna have a
vegas night
that'll be great why don't you guys come
out and see me in vegas come out there
with your boys get drunk get a [ __ ]
hooker
right couple of call girls luck
be a lady tonight
put on a condom that's right
and even afterwards you jump in the
shower
and wash your crotch real good
you should have just had her blow you
are you [ __ ] nuts why'd you go inside
who [ __ ] knows what's in that [ __ ]
couch see this is why i have to close
the windows i can't do this people have
kids in this building
i'll tell you this water this pollen
spring water that was probably bottled
nine years ago and put in a warehouse is
absolutely [ __ ] delicious
how do they keep the algae off of it do
you know my i have a [ __ ] um
i have a water fountain in my front yard
and i know you're thinking jesus your
house must be amazing it isn't
and neither is the water fountain it's
this little douchey it's like
it's like somewhere between like a
[ __ ] bird bath
and something jesus would wash his you
know wash uh
maybe you're feeding right he wouldn't
wash his feet because that would
actually be doing something for himself
which he never did
he never did anything for himself he did
it all for you
and thanks a lot for not appreciating
them
if you turn your pages oh i was going to
go to church today
i was actually going to do that why
don't i go because i can get up to
[ __ ] 12.
i like doing that every once in a while
just going
going down there and remembering that
i'm gonna go to some fiery [ __ ] grave
um
uh so anyway so i got this little stupid
glorified bird bath that they're calling
a fountain
and uh i i just for life me i can't keep
the thing clean
there's just algae all over the [ __ ]
place there's goddamn mosquitoes
laying eggs in there so then i gotta go
out and go buy all this [ __ ]
poison and stick it in the water
you know and then what happens and some
other animal comes by and goes oh wow
look at the goddamn water i think i'll
have a drink
and then i [ __ ] whack this skunk or a
raccoon or some other [ __ ] uh
varmint you know and technically those
things are
varmints i know what's his face you're
sending me sam gave that
gave that word a bad name well actually
is a rabbit considered a varmint
maybe it is i was just told you know if
you had hair you were a mammal i didn't
know what varmint is varmint like a
racial slur for a mammal
does that word mean [ __ ] in their
world because i know like a skunk
possum
what else is a raccoon those are all
varmints
like when you're when you're a redneck
or a serial killer you know that's
that's what you start with
except rednecks for the most part they
stop at like elk
where if you're you're a serial killer
you keep going
but i don't think you work your way up
to elk you know
i think you you kill like a
uh like an adolescent bear and then you
kill a fat person and then that's that's
the
that's that's the off ramp you take
right
how many [ __ ] minutes am i in what am
i talking about
oh jesus 22 [ __ ] minutes in can i can
i put out an ep this week
is that good you know it'd be great if
somebody has to [ __ ] question ania
and then i could do another one of those
epilogues and then i'll [ __ ] splice
it back on like i'm reattaching a limp
wouldn't that be phenomenal you can't
believe this [ __ ] that i watched this
week
on youtube i watched some [ __ ] about
some soldiers coming back from iraq
talking about all the horrible stuff
they did taking their medals off
throwing them
and that type of [ __ ] and uh
ah you know i don't know
just can't wrap my [ __ ] head around
it's too much too much to take in and
that's the thing
i needed to watch football i needed a
little bread and circus
as the old expression goes right
whenever the people are ready to revolt
against the king
they sent out some bread and they sent
some tumblers down there and some people
to tell jokes and everybody got
shit-faced their bellies were full of
bread and they're like ah the king's all
right
well we'll attack the castle tomorrow
right maybe sent down a couple of
harlots isn't that what they did or did
am i remembering like an episode of like
uh game of thrones
i want to start watching that show i
watched a couple episodes and that
little kid is just so [ __ ] evil man
you know he's like a whole nother level
like a children of the corn
that kid i mean that little bastard
is there anything more hateable than a
kid in power
you know i wonder if they got whacked
more than an adult
an adult you actually you can at least
think that maybe they work to get the
job but you know when you're sitting
there taking [ __ ]
you know some eight-year-old kid off
with his head his [ __ ] voice hasn't
even changed
i have to learn how to scream properly
on stage
[ __ ] voice gets like this every
goddamn weekend ah let's read some more
[ __ ] advertising for christ's sake at
least i can get that in right
i'll get that in before this thing
slowly peters out
you know actually you know when you
think about it isn't this kind of a nice
way to start the week
i feel like you know i feel i'm speaking
in the same voice like someone speaks in
like the end of a yoga class
i hope you guys all have a wonderful
week and just remember
some of the lessons that you've learned
over the last hour connecting
letting go getting in touch with that
voice inside you
sorry i know this is creepy um all right
e-voice everybody
would you like to turn your life around
would you like to start a business
without having to actually have a place
where it exists wouldn't that be awesome
wouldn't it be great if you could act
and make it sound like you actually had
an office
well e-voice gives you that ability you
don't have to buy another cell phone
because with the wonder of e-voice you
can get
a bunch of cell phone numbers for your
cell phone and once again i forget what
the word is
why do i always want to say viral phone
numbers why don't i write it down on
this copy
virtual you can get a bunch of virtual
phone numbers you can walk up to
somebody
with a cell phone that is a number
another number to it and say this is my
business number
okay and then they think they call in
office because
they also have uh their professional uh
voice over actors for your answering
machine
they'll pick it up and make it seem like
you have some james bond
maybe partner or some sexy co-worker or
something
like that they get call forwarding
toll-free 1-800 numbers
um automatic attendant advanced
voicemail voicemail the text voicemail
to email
uh e-voice is perfect for business
for the business for a business person
on the move um
click on the e-voice banner on
billboard.com podcast page or go to
www.evoice.com
billboard to get your exclusive
six-month free trial
e-voice your mobile phone at work i mean
that's tremendous
that really is tremendous i wish they
had that when i was starting out but you
know then again i didn't have an idea
for a business
i wish i could have utilized that back
in the day when i wasn't smart
what do you guys think about the
patriots ravens tonight
you know what do you think what do you
think
i'm worried that tom brady's going to
get hurt tonight i got to be honest with
you we got
a rookie protecting the [ __ ] blind
side i don't like it
i don't like it we're good against the
run but all they got to do old joe
flacco himself
if he finally plays up to his potential
all right
they all they got to do is just go into
the hurry up offense that's all they got
to do and they're going to go right down
the goddamn field
um all right let's read some [ __ ] uh
let's read some questions for this week
we're on the we're on this side of the
half hour and i'm already into the
questions can you believe that
i know what you're not i know something
that you can absolutely believe is that
i can't find where the [ __ ] the
questions are in the goddamn podcast
oh there they are all right oh here's a
pet peeve of mine in new york that i
completely forgot about when you walk
down the street
um like how [ __ ] angry you can get
you know when you're walking behind
somebody and you're trying to go past
them because they're walking too slow
and they they serpentine down the
sidewalk it's like they're they're
either doing it on purpose or their
[ __ ] equilibrium is off
you just want to punch them in the back
every time you go left they start going
left you cut back right
then you do that [ __ ] evil exhale in
their [ __ ] ear and it startles them
you know if it was the movie they'd drop
a bag and a grapefruit would roll out
it's always a great thing great visual
in movies to let people know that that
character was startled because they
dropped a bag of fruit
yeah and it's always rollable fruit it's
never a banana
it would just fall there like a [ __ ]
receiver off a goddamn phone
um and then also how when you're walking
down the street and a lovely lady's
coming your way and there's not enough
room for both here you start to turn
right you start to turn and she doesn't
turn at all
like she's a goddess you know
it's just how far do i have to take this
gentlemanly thing why don't
how come i have to adjust my body 100
you don't even they don't even [ __ ]
look at you they just
like stare straight ahead you know what
i used to do in new york i had this
passive aggressive [ __ ] move that i
would do
i i had a um you always have like a bag
if you're gonna be out for a while
you know you don't have a car so you got
all your [ __ ] like a [ __ ] backpack
i'd have it slung over one shoulder and
if somebody was not going to get out of
my [ __ ] way as or
wasn't even making an attempt to adjust
their body as they were walking by me
and i got to do all the [ __ ] moving
right like this unhealthy [ __ ]
relationship
what i do is right as they're about
ready to pass me
i'd have my bag on my right shoulder
there on my left what i would do is
right as they're going by me i would
turn around and look over my right
shoulder turning my back
and whacking them with the bag and then
i'd immediately turn around be like oh
i'm sorry
sorry about that you know totally
[ __ ] passive progress that's how
that's how i handled that [ __ ]
because i wasn't man enough to just
punch him in the face
um all right here's one
from a lady hey bill what kind of
sunscreen do you use
um i unfortunately don't really use
sunscreen
when i do use it uh i don't go higher
than 50.
if you try to use when i use the 100
it's so thick it like pulls my arm hair
off
it feels like glue
you know sunscreen 100 feels like glue
but i'll use 50
35 but the key is you got to wear a hat
because you can't put sunscreen above
your eyes because it drips down and
it gets all stingy you know i don't put
it on my face too much
i got i got a beard and a hat i think
i'm all right
um i don't know
does that answer your question we just
really saying you're a pasty
[ __ ] and uh
i know you use it are you a fellow
redhead
is that what you are i don't [ __ ]
know
um a lady roommate hey bill huge fan of
the show wanted to see if you had any
advice for this situation i found myself
in a little over a month ago i moved to
phoenix
and moved in with the friend of oh yeah
did you go up camelback mountain yet
that's a [ __ ] great hike you got to
go up that one somebody dies up there
every [ __ ] year which always cracks
me up
to be like alone in the wilderness while
you can actually see buildings
in the distance it's gotta be so
frustrating
um little ugly ass [ __ ] roadrunners
all right a little over a month ago i
moved to phoenix and moved in with a
friend
from college no real problems there but
he did have a female college age
roommate that he got along with
so we ended up setting settling on a
three bedroom
all right so it's two dudes and a chick
this is already like a sitcom this is
like [ __ ] reverse threes company
come on nugget my door loose waiting for
you
well it gives us remember [ __ ]
america was just like that you know
nice and simple i guess it was probably
[ __ ] up then i was just too young to
notice
sitting there eating a popsicle
[Music]
larry's upstairs 50 years old [ __ ]
everything that moves
um all right i only know a few people in
town
and my work schedule is grueling it
makes it really hard to meet too
too many people over the course of the
week all right so you're setting up your
excuse for why you're already [ __ ]
your friend's
friend all right you know i work a lot i
can't get to meet people uh
why go out for [ __ ] when it's right
next door i get it buddy i get it
you know it's discovery channel does the
lion go after the toughest zebra or the
[ __ ] wounded one
or the little baby one am i the one
walking around wearing the [ __ ] juicy
shorts
i'm sure by now you've pinpointed the
key word in the above paragraph female
yes i
am sir yes i have so you can see where
this is going
my second weekend here we all go out get
sloppy jalopy drunk
and she informs me that she broke up
with her boyfriend of five
years ah wonderful so of course i do the
gentlemanly thing
and [ __ ] her brains out oh we go so of
course
yeah i do the gentleman thing and [ __ ]
her brains out
or flop around like a dead fish on top
of her
um it's one of those two once i'm done i
leave i go to my room
and we don't mention in we don't mention
you don't mention it in the morning and
it's not awkward at all
if i had the alleluia song
oh that's [ __ ] great
would you guys look down at me if i told
you that i was just jealous of this
person right now
that's [ __ ] perfect and the hardest
thing is going to be for you
to not [ __ ] this up for you not to
develop feelings
okay you know
that's going to be a hard one but if you
could somehow do it if you could somehow
keep yourself separated
you know you could just it would be like
uh
it'd be like stamps.com having the post
office in your [ __ ] apartment now you
got the post ops in your apartment
and now you have this [ __ ] machine
also there i mean it's just
tremendous you know
and then all you got to do is just
decide what what kind of food
you're always going out for and you
really like and you buy that appliance
be it a panini maker
or a [ __ ] cappuccino maker you got
that stamps.com and the [ __ ] machine
down the hall and i tell you
that's it get the nfl package
call it a life um
so anyways he goes work we've gone about
doing this for a few weeks now but since
i'm never home during the week and she
works during the day and weekends we
don't exactly see each other and when we
do
we we literally never say anything about
it or hint
at it at all etc dude please don't [ __ ]
this
up please don't [ __ ] this up
okay he says my question
being as this is the first time
something like this has happened
is this a time bomb waiting to happen
where all the crazy is going to come
flying out like the ark of the covenant
or is she just rebounding and i'm the
free and clear until i
settle in and find something else keep
in mind keep in mind that jesus christ
sorry didn't go to church today has died
for rose
and has risen from the grave
he did it all for you there's no way
for you to thank him
[Music]
unless you give us a bunch of money um
keep in mind i've never
been accused of being good looking and
she's pretty cute with a
grade a ass on her any advice is
appreciated and i guess go [ __ ] yourself
um okay
all right you did the right thing you
know you got a great situation and you
don't want to [ __ ] it up
you know this is like the first time i
went deep sea fishing i got a bite and i
looked at the dude next to me am i doing
it right what do i do
i'll let it run a little bit let her run
a little bit bring it in right
you're doing the same thing all right so
what is your question here
is this a time what this this is okay
there's
there's the wild card that she's a
psycho but she she she would have shown
her colors by now i would think if she
was a psycho
you know there would have been some sort
of
you know god you work so much i don't
get to see you
i just want to see you more
[Music]
doing that you know [ __ ] twisting
your arm hair or doing
something [ __ ] annoying some sort of
annoying sort of touching right
so she hasn't done that she's totally
putting out the vibe that
she's basically in the mindset it's this
thing seems like it's exactly what it is
you know she was in a relationship for
five years
five years man she's gotta decompress
from that all right
she likes to go out and get hammered and
get [ __ ] and go to bed
and not see your dumbass for the whole
week all right
just keep it at that this is the deal
you don't ever bring it up either
you don't ever bring it up either just
keep it the way it is
all right if she's barely talking to you
you barely talk to her
and you just have fun with it and this
is another thing you do
all right have fun with this [ __ ]
what are some things that you always
wanted to do with the woman and you
haven't done yet
this is the girl you do it with all
right
and she's gonna probably do it with you
too because she doesn't give a [ __ ]
about you
which is a great thing what you have sir
is a [ __ ] buddy
congratulations this is your first one
this is what men dream of
this is what men really want for this is
what we want for christmas
you know if we could just have a [ __ ]
buddy
somebody who was clean with no diseases
you know and somehow then had this pill
they could give you
that you drank you know you washed it
down and it got rid of any sort of
[ __ ] guilt
it would be perfect but you're single
dude so there's no guilt so
my thing is just don't don't open your
mouth and [ __ ] this thing up
all right you got a great thing going
okay just keep doing what you're doing
and uh the only thing i would correct is
this whole thing where you say you know
i'm not that good looking a guy
you know work on your self-esteem
she's pretty cute hey you know
good for her she's got a nice ass why
don't you go [ __ ] do something to it
but not during the week no [ __ ]
during the week you focus on your job
you have a great [ __ ] time
i know it you know i guess eventually if
you do meet somebody and you start
bringing them around
there's but there is a potential but
uh you just got to nip that [ __ ] in the
butt i guess if you actually met
somebody that you liked
uh ah jesus
i just yeah i didn't think about that
all right first first things first
before we even get
over to her uh i mean
just okay whole new can of worms here
dude you have to be cool first and
foremost
all right because eventually you know
if she meets some other dude you got to
make sure that you're not going to flip
out
so do not develop any feelings for this
girl
and the only way you're not gonna
develop any feelings for this girl is if
you see her once a [ __ ] week and your
banger
okay you don't want to know how many
brothers and sisters she has
right it's like reservoir dogs you guys
shouldn't even know each other's names
tell me your name don't tell me your
[ __ ] i don't know your name yeah you
don't know you don't you want that all
right
all right you [ __ ] mr pink or
whatever she's mr blonde
or mrs blonde sorry um
that's the only thing you got to worry
about all right
so and i've learned to just be totally
[ __ ] upfront and honest so if i got
some new girlfriend
i would just tell her what's up so
what's your deal yeah i'm single i'm
kind of banging my [ __ ] roommate once
a week
you know we don't you know it's just
sort of a [ __ ] buddy thing
oh does that make you uncomfortable well
all right well then this relationship
isn't gonna work because you're already
uncomfortable with me
no if i got feelings for you i wouldn't
keep banging her but you know
i'm not taking it off the table after
one [ __ ] trip to applebee's
jesus christ free [ __ ] that's like free
shoes for you
right you know i don't know
that's all like all i can tell you dude
you can't control her who gives a [ __ ]
dude
someday you're going to be 50 and you're
going to be married
and she's going to be bitching at you
about something any of your lover you at
some point you're just going to be
reminiscing going you know when my life
was the greatest
was when i had that little [ __ ]
goddamn
three-bedroom apartment all i had to do
was make this amount of money a week and
i had some chick once a week would just
[ __ ] my brains out and not talk to me
for the other six days
goddamn dream you got the dream sir all
right
and i don't know where you're gonna wake
up
but enjoy it while it okay
i hope i answered your question i really
do you're in a hell of a situation enjoy
it
all right kudos to you i am jealous
all right never buy the largest bottle
of [ __ ] water
you bring it back down it splashes in
your face
um all right next one here
you know i was actually just thinking
about that whole new world order thing
the new world order say they're going to
get the population down to [ __ ] 90
i know you guys are flipping out how do
you even do that
do you know does the whole world just
all st
somehow the world leaders all finally
agree all right
we're all doing the same thing starting
today we're all going to kill
90 percent of our citizens like how
would you even begin
how would you even begin that endeavor
well we just knocking door to door hey
guess
guess who's not on the right list come
on
pack up your stuff
oh who gives a [ __ ] all right plowing
ahead here
um dad's getting a little too
comfortable hey bill
my brother and i live in our father's
house
and recently he decided it's okay to
walk around the house and nothing but
sweatpants
when he comes home he's gotten pretty
fat over the last couple of months
and it's pretty disgusting to see his
uh you wrote giggly you mean jiggly
hairy stomach and tits around while i'm
trying to watch tv
or work at home he also tells me what to
do even though he's kind of a piece of
[ __ ]
uh he's a he's the type that would get
mad if you confronted him
and start wearing almost nothing at all
oh nothing all the time or worse somehow
what should i do
um well i don't know write a song called
dad put your shirt on i don't [ __ ]
know
first of all you know what you're going
to do you got to get over your this this
whole
this whole [ __ ] fear of confronting
your dad you just got to get over it
just
confront the guy and if he starts
walking around in his dvds you guys just
sit around you and your brother or your
sister you just ridicule him
just start chanting tub [ __ ] talk about
[ __ ] something
i don't know what to tell you
you know why don't you just say uh
how could you do it maybe just you act
like you're giving him a compliment but
you're insulting him
he just comes walking in just be like
hey nice tits
and then as he goes to [ __ ] respond
you just sing that song that doesn't
exist
you just [ __ ] walk away don't listen
to him
that's gotta be the greatest set of
hairy tits i've seen
but up up you know just start making
songs up
oh theory is oh thank god you know
thank god i was worrying that i wasn't
going to get to see you half naked today
this is awesome dad could you do me a
favor i know you've done so many
wonderful things for me
is there any way you could get fatter
you know could i buy some rogaine and
just you know
have you sprinkle it on your [ __ ]
chest so you could be even more
sweaty and hairy and fat could you do
that for me dad
that's awesome you know do you have any
consideration for mom whatsoever
she must have been attracted to you at
some point right
are you so fat you can't even wear a
hoodie just just do just roast the guy
all right here we go let's just [ __ ]
plow ahead here
all right yeah why don't you do that
write some old school jokes all those
yet tits so you're [ __ ] deep adopted
just fill it in i'm turning old friend
into girlfriend
all right wait a minute i already read
that one
no this is a new one all right bill love
the podcast would really like
yours and nia's if possible thoughts on
the subject
oh you want nia she's not here i might
be time for another little
[ __ ] mmp epilogue
i'll see if she's up for it i'm only in
town for a day and a half i don't know
if i have to
you know what i'll do another one you
guys like the last one so much all right
here we go there's a girl there's a girl
i know with the hipsters gold called
[ __ ] badoo twist twist uh
i should really hand out a free dvd for
everybody knows that song but i won't
because there's too many flintstones
fans out there
that was the bedrock song um there's a
girl i've been friends with for over a
decade now
we met in college and for about a year
or two
back then i would have considered her
one of my closest friends
you ever start reading and you're just
not even listening to what you're saying
you guys mind if i go back
um is this a guy what are we doing here
um there's a girl i've been friends with
for over a decade now we met in college
and for about a year or two back then
i would have considered her one of my
closest friends
during that whole time she had a
boyfriend so i never thought about
making a move and lacked the confidence
to do so
anyway as time went on we gradually lost
contact until recently when i found her
on facebook
well how did you do that until recently
when you searched her on facebook
because you were thinking about her
if you just said that that would have
been so much less creepier than to say
until recently when i
uh found her on facebook oh wait you
kind of did say that
am i even listening to what i'm saying
i'm sorry sir i'm an [ __ ]
anyways plowing ahead and we spoke for
the first time
in eight years we live in the same city
so i suggested we get together and catch
up
which she is enthusiastic about and is
going it is going to happen sometime
soon now for the details we are both
single and 30 years old
she has recently divorced no kids clean
break with little
or to no drama she's beautiful and
honestly one of the nicest people i've
ever met
back when we were close i was okay
looking but extremely skinny and shy
since then i put on about 25 to 30
pounds of
fat and muscle distributed pretty evenly
i like this guy he's honest
uh so i'm looking much better
and that has boosted my confidence uh my
question
she has only known me as the friend zone
guy
but does eight years with no count or
racist yes
um and do you think i might have a shot
with her yes
and any advice about how to go about and
how to act
and what to say on the night we catch up
would be greatly appreciated thanks in
advance
p.s one thing may be an issue here
she doesn't have herpes does she um
after i suggested
a ketchup i checked out her facebook
page and it turns out that she changed
her set
her status from married to single only a
day
or two earlier but in real life she said
she'd been single for a few months
so that was inadvertent rotten
timing on my part hopefully i don't come
across as tactless
opportunistic douchebag no dude you're
[ __ ] overthinking that
unless she was sitting there watching
her facebook page every day like a
[ __ ]
day trader waiting for her to get
through that divorce
then it would be creepy but other than
that now dude you're a good guy sound
like a good guy anyways all right so
what is your question
okay yeah dude you're not in the friend
zone anymore you're a whole new guy
okay you like the uh you you know it's
like you had up you had a makeover you
got some [ __ ]
you got a little braun going you got
some confidence
um you definitely have a shot with her
she probably was dating [ __ ] back
then and when she's going
through that [ __ ] she was probably
thinking you know what this time around
i'm gonna get a nice guy
you know who i should have got with he
was just the nicest guy
for some reason i just never [ __ ]
blah blah blah and we were such
good friends she probably had that
conversation when she got to the part
where she said
and we were such good friends she
clasped both of her girlfriend's hands
and her hands
you know there's probably some crumpled
up tissues in her lap
as they you know she was getting through
her divorce
oh look at me painting a picture i think
you're in there
all right now don't overthink this [ __ ]
okay
because you're acting like this girl's
already the one you don't [ __ ] know
you haven't seen her in eight years so
just walk
in there [ __ ] and have a good time
throw your dick on the table and ask her
how she's been
what's up sweetheart the [ __ ] you
been doing for the last decade huh
hey couple more drinks over here sorry
dick jokes end of the podcast sorry
people
um
yeah that's what i would do are you
funny make a laugh
that always works
tell us she looks good just oh look at
you you look great give her a nice hug
or something you know if she goes for
the hug give her a hug
oh my god that's the big thing when you
walk in do not
[ __ ] shake her hand do not shake her
hand
don't go for the hug if you're not a
good hugger but do not shake her hand
oh if you're not a hugger then what the
[ __ ] you gonna do oh you gotta hug her
this is what you do you [ __ ] act like
de niro and goodfellas after the
luffwanza heist whatever the [ __ ] it was
come here you
come here you ah jimmy you gotta have
that [ __ ] vibe
come here yo that's what you do what's
the matter with you um
yeah just have a bring it in give her a
nice [ __ ] hug
and you have a couple of drinks you know
what i mean
let's see what happens just don't don't
overthink it you're gonna end up
psyching yourself up
that's the only thing now what the hell
else did i want to talk about oh this
week everybody
this week oh billy redface he's winding
up in new york
and then i'm going down to jacksonville
florida jacksonville florida everybody
gonna go down there watch some people
wrestle some gators um i've actually
never been there only thing i know about
jacksonville is they have the
jaguars which i'm going to the game on
sunday and then they also have uh
florida plays georgia there every year
the biggest cocktail
party in the universe they say stadium
holds like 60 000 people and like
[ __ ] 800 000 people show up just to
tailgate
i imagine they make most of their
[ __ ] money for the year
um sounds pretty awesome so somebody's
already reached out
said they'd take me shooting i want to
go skate shooting
you know i want to do something like
that i want to do something [ __ ] real
goddamn rednecky i went to [ __ ] the
drag strip last week why not you're in
jacksonville
when in rome um so i'll be at the comedy
zone tickets are going fast everybody
believe it or not
never been there they're going fast
maybe to yell at me for call making fun
of this city
um and then the week after that i go to
cincinnati
baby if you ever wondered
wonder whatever became of me
i'm telling jokes at a [ __ ] mall
a [ __ ] strip mall in cincinnati
um now where do i go after that then i
come back to new york
and then i go to australia to play the
uh
the opera house you know when they show
whenever they show pictures of sydney
and they got that little
that little clamshell thing they got a
little club in there like a 400 seater
and i'm doing uh i'm doing three three
nights there i believe and then i'm
doing it's
some big comedy festival out there i'm
really excited about it and then i'm
gonna stay for an extra couple of days
and believe it or not
i think i'm going to go snorkeling
in the great barrier reef why wouldn't
you
uh because you don't want to get eaten
by a shark that's my big thing i go i
don't want to get eaten by a [ __ ]
shark i don't a great white shark
is what the guy oh no that water's too
hot for great whites oh good so the
other
thousand species of sharks those are the
only ones i gotta worry about
hammerheads tigers they got barracuda
out there
first of all all i want to do is take
the boat out look at it like no you got
to stick your face in the water and see
all the colors
so i'm going to do it i'm going to roll
the dice you know why because people do
it
every [ __ ] day and they don't die
every once in a while somebody dies
so so why not you bill
that's what i always come back to oh
gives a [ __ ] what would you rather do
would you rather be in an underwater die
in an underwater like wonderland
getting ripped to shreds by some monster
or uh
die slowly in a fema camp smelling other
people's feet i mean it's just it's just
no good way to go
unless you go in your sleep you know
with headphones on listening to like
parade music
wouldn't that be nice um all right what
do we got here overrated underrated
for this week bill huge fan
first off get the [ __ ] back to melbourne
again what's with this cindy
sydney [ __ ] uh sydney only [ __ ]
well i've never performed i guess i did
melbourne that one time but that was a
comedy central thing
uh anyways i have a couple of
underrateds for you first
uh first underrated rapping over heavy
guitar riffs
and rap songs with guitar solos in them
why the hell isn't anyone doing this
anymore i was listening to some old run
dmc
songs like raising hell and tougher than
leather and that [ __ ]
is the tits secondly underrated patrice
o'neal
sadly i never saw any of his stuff until
he passed
[ __ ] shattered about that caught his
elephant in the room
special and it's [ __ ] epic clearly
one of the best
will be buying his entire catalog asap
that's awesome man
um yeah he was he was just getting known
by the masses he but he was not
underrated with fellow comedians believe
me
believe me um so yeah if you buy um
if you buy mr p all the proceeds goes to
uh goes to his mom so that's a cool
thing to do
and uh yeah man he's unreal i still
can't talk about that [ __ ]
um anyways plowing ahead the monday
morning podcast this is what it's been
people 55 minutes
55 minutes that's what you're getting
this week as i sit in my goddamn hot
apartment but you know something you're
going to get the epilogue
when nia answers uh whatever the hell
that question was i want to thank all
you guys for listening and uh
and seriously no [ __ ] not joking i
want to thank everybody for coming out
to these shows you know i had eight
shows here in caroline's and they
they've all been packed
i went to two cities that i've you know
orlando i never performed in they were
packed all weekend
charlotte was all packed and i'm hearing
that jacksonville and cincinnati
is uh is looking like it's going to be
the same thing so um
you know it's [ __ ] unreal it's unreal
you know what i mean it's one of those
deals where every time you're going to
the club you peek your hit your head in
going like is this the show where it all
starts going back the other way and you
see it's all the way to the back you're
like thank god
fool them for another day um so
seriously i want to thank everybody
who's come out
and uh i'm feeling great about my new
hour
i'm actually going to be taping
something for comedy central
i'm doing that night night of too many
stars
i know that is the worst name ever
there's just too many stars i was joking
with the guy who booked me i was like if
they said if they said night of too many
douchebags that would have been all over
but uh i don't know evidently it's
booked by this major guy and it's some
guy that i should know
and it'd be a good thing if i did it for
the career so you know i got to do it i
got to jump on another
goddamn plane and right now i'm thinking
about which bits what bit for my new
hour am i going to burn
i think i'm going to do the steve jobs
bit that's the game plan i'm going to do
that one because
i don't think that that has enough legs
until my next special it might if i can
tag it on to something else
i'm going to put it out there at the
risk of offending a bunch of [ __ ]
nerds who are into technology i always
think no matter how [ __ ]
offensive i get the fact that you can
just see through to how [ __ ]
uninformed or stupid i am depending on
how you you read me uh that
that kind of you know takes some of the
sting out of it right did i already
begin the apology for what the [ __ ] i'm
gonna say
i think i did all right that is a
podcast you guys follow me on twitter
remember that thing i said i'd never do
i'd never tweet
i actually um nia sent me a clip of the
uh the official trailer for the movie
stand up guys
remember back in uh april i i um
didn't do a podcast or on a monday and
it was really late
and i said one day i would tell you i
would give you a great excuse
as opposed to all the other weeks when
it's late just because i'm an idiot
uh one of those weeks i was shooting uh
those scenes and then that movie stars
uh
al pacino christopher walken and alan
arkin
and uh yeah so i was laughing when
everyone's like where the [ __ ] is the
podcast you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
and i so wanted to be like well i had to
do some scenes
with some of the greatest actors of all
time sorry i'm late
you know granted i only have a couple of
words but it's big to me
um so anyways the the official trailer
if you're
if you're uh if you sign up for me on
twitter
um you can see it or you can just go on
[ __ ] youtube who's getting
just trying to get more twitter
followers if you're already listening to
this [ __ ] do you need to be over there
too
you don't it's redundant that's like i
have your cell phone number and now i'm
asking for your home phone number you
know what
don't follow me on twitter how about
that all right that's the podcast for
this week go [ __ ] yourselves
um i'm really hoping my patriots are
gonna win this week
um i'm actually watching the patriots in
a different way this year because i
don't i don't think we're good enough
i just don't think anybody in the afc is
good enough to [ __ ] with the nfc
although
the 49ers lost to the vikings today so
who knows who knows
um but i'm just excited to watch
hopefully the development of uh
chandler jones i just hope he turns into
a first ballot hall of fame
defensive absolute [ __ ] nightmare for
the other team that just comes in and
just
disrupts every pass play just something
that we we've never had
we've never had close thing we had to
that was andre tippett
you know and he was a linebacker we've
had some great linebackers bruce steve
rabel and all those guys willie mcginnis
you know but we've never had a hall of
fame
i don't think we ever had nick bonicon
is the only one we ever had we traded
him to miami
because we thought he was too small and
he was like i'll show you two small
there's an undefeated season
and two back-to-back super bowls go [ __ ]
yourself thank you for the hall of fame
jacket
um all right that's it i'll talk to you
guys next week go [ __ ] yourselves